-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
I'm Jimmy Fallon.
Let's get to some news here.
Well, guys, today is July 27th,
and you know what that means.
-99 days.
-99 days away from
the presidential election.
-That's right -- we are just
99 days away from election
and just 100 days away
from President Trump
declaring the results invalid.
Yep, just 99 days
or, as one man put it,
[ Russian accent ] "So much
hacking, so little time."
[ Normal voice ] Trump thinks
99 days is plenty of time
to get his campaign in shape.
He's like someone looking in
the mirror in June going,
"I've still got time
for swimsuit season."
99 days.
That's like an entire baseball
season plus 96 days.
Yeah, 99 days
doesn't seem like that much.
Then again, the last 99 days
have felt like 900 years, so...
The clock is ticking on Trump's
chances to turn things around.
Today, he saw his approval
rating in the low 30s
and spent the morning screaming
into his MyPillow.
With just 99 days left,
it looks like Joe Biden
is choose --
close to choosing -- Sorry.
I got screwed because no one
laughed at that last one,
but it's alright.
I know, but if you hear it --
Maybe if you hear it at home --
-What's MyPillow?
-It was so funny!
-The MyPillow
guy is the guy that --
It's his, like, biggest
supporter, yeah, is MyPillow.
[ Laugh track ]
No, it's too late.
-Keep it in there.
-No, no.
-Oh, it's good.
-It's not worth it.
Well, with just 99 days left,
it looks like Joe Biden
is close to choosing
a running mate this week,
and he's now personally
interviewing all the candidates.
He said, "I'm going to ask you
the same question
Obama asked me -- do you know
how to play the quiet game?"
That's right -- Joe is asking
the hard-hitting questions like,
"Do you have organize experience
organizing pills?"
Stuff like that.
It will be a wake-up call
when Biden says,
"Where do you see yourself
in five years?",
and the candidates are like,
"President."
Well, guys, over the weekend,
while discussing
Trump's response to
the pandemic,
Nancy Pelosi said that her new
nickname for Trump is
"Mr. Make Matters Worse."
For more, I'm joined by
Kevin Cipriano,
the person who writes
the clever nicknames
that Nancy Pelosi uses.
Hey. Kevin, How did you come up
with the nickname
Mr. Make Matters Worse?
-Well, first, I started with
Trump's gender, which is man.
So that's where I got
the "Mr." part.
And as far as the
"Makes Matters Worse" part,
I thought, "What is Trump
doing that's upsetting
so many people right now?"
And that's obvious.
It's the way
he handles matters, right?
And what does he do to matters?
Well, he makes them worse.
And that's how the
famous nickname was born.
Now everyone calls Trump
"Mr. Make Matters Worse."
-I don't think anyone but Pelosi
is calling him that.
No offense,
but people are saying
it's not the best nickname ever.
-Well, it's not my
proudest work.
I came up with a nickname
for Betsy DeVos
that's pretty devastating.
You know how she's
the Secretary of Education?
-Yeah.
-Well, my nickname for her --
"The Secretary of Miseducation
of the American People."
-Yeah, I think you're hitting
the same wall there.
Nicknames are usually catchy.
-Well, I only have to answer to
Speaker Pelosi,
and let me tell you,
these names are very funny
to an 80-year-old woman
who is extremely stressed.
-That's great,
but just as an example,
Dwayne Johnson's nickname
was "The Rock,"
not "The Large Man Who is
Good at Both Punching
and Acting."
-Okay. Fine, Jimmy.
I'll come clean.
I know these names aren't good.
I get it.
But Nancy loves them.
She told me the key to
a great nickname
is for it to be --
and I quote --
"Very long and also
impossible to remember."
Being Nancy Pelosi's
nickname writer is my dream job.
Don't ruin this for me.
-Hey, it's okay. I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to upset you.
-Maybe I can run
some other nicknames by you,
and you tell me if you think
Speaker Pelosi would like them.
-Yeah. Sure.
I mean, it seems she and I
have different tastes,
but, yeah, let's give it a shot.
-Okay, this one's for
Steve Scalise,
who's a member of the House.
[ Clears throat ]
Member of the house, huh?
More like "Member of the House,
and The House is a House
of Cards that is Tumbling Down."
-That's all one nickname?
-Loud and clear, Jimmy.
But this next one is
a perfect burn.
It's for Mike Pence.
"The Vice Presi-don't
of the Un-United States
of Ameri-don't."
-Not sure I completely
get that one.
I think you have better stuff.
-Okay, Mitch McConnell --
"Captain of the S.S. Nonsense,
All Aboard, Toot-toot!"
-You pronounce "comma" in the --
Look, it seems like
the other ones
Pelosi likes, kind of,
so I won't say it's good,
but maybe she'll like that one.
-Jimmy, you just saved
my career.
Now I can go back to
helping the Democrats
fight the Trump administration
the best way we know how --
with sass.
[ Imitates sizzling, laughs ]
-Kevin Cipriano, everybody.
[ Applause ]
And get this --
the other day, Trump said
that he'd be throwing out
the first pitch
at a Yankees game next month.
Let's see how those plans
are holding up.
-President Trump says
he won't be throwing out
the first pitch at
Yankee Stadium
on August 15th after all.
The president tweeted that
he's focusing on
coronavirus meetings
and the economy
and can't be there that day.
-Yeah. Trump won't be throwing
out the first pitch.
Although, thanks to
his handling of the pandemic,
he might be able to throw out
the last pitch
of the season tomorrow.
I wish Trump didn't cancel,
mostly because I wanted to see
him slowly walk down
the pitcher's mound.
[ As Trump ] See, the dirt
is very slippery --
very, very slippery --
and I'm wearing leather shoes.
And everyone knows,
when you wear leather shoes
on slippery pitcher's mounds,
it's hard to get down
off the mound.
[ Normal voice ]
It's kind of sad that Trump
cancelled throwing the ball.
When he heard that,
Don Jr. was like,
"Eh, you get used to it."
Well, Trump
skipping the first pitch
isn't the news baseball fans
are upset about today.
The season's
just a few days old,
and, already, there's trouble.
-ESPN reporting the
Miami Marlins' home opener
tonight has been cancelled.
Eight more players
and two coaches
have now tested positive
for coronavirus.
In all, 14 people in the
clubhouse have tested positive.
-14 players and coaches
on one team
have already tested positive
just days into the season.
But, by all means,
let's reopen schools.
That's a tough break for
the Marlins
and Major League Baseball.
I mean, besides everyone,
who saw this coming?
I mean, who knew a sport where
guys spend three hours a day
spitting and high-fiving
would put people at risk?
That's right -- half the Marlins
tested positive.
Even worse,
the team is replacing
those players with Dr. Fauci.
Aaaah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
Whoa!
And if Dr. Fauci
isn't available,
they could try to get
Questlove.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh! Ooh!
-Not funny, man.
-Hey!
-Oh, check this out.
I saw that Bugatti is now
selling a $35,000 car for kids.
Take a look at this thing.
It comes with two driving modes,
a battery pack,
and a guarantee that every other
parent will hate you.
And, finally, the app TikTok
announced that they plan to add
10,000 new jobs
to the U.S. economy
over the next three years.
You know, I was wondering
what those jobs might be
until I saw this commercial
on TV late last night.
Check this out.
-In today's world, finding
the right career can be tough.
But, luckily,
there's a place that can help.
At TikTok Career College,
we give you
the resources and training
you need to build your career
in America's booming
TikTok industry.
Whether you want to
earn your master's
in adding text to screen,
pointing at text on screen,
or pointing at people who are
we've got you covered.
America's attention span
is shrinking,
but the business of catering to
that shrinking attention span
is growing.
-Without TikTok Career College,
I'd have no idea
how to hit that whoa,
bonk that Nae Nae,
or make my grandpa dress up like
Chuckie from "Rugrats"
and lip-sync
the little-baby song.
Thanks, TikTok Career College.
-At TikTok Career College,
your professors are
the best in their field.
I can't believe I got to study
add the feet of
Dat Girl, TurtTurt,
and Zanny Devito.
-I used to work in retail,
but then I realized
I could earn a lot more
with a degree from
TikTok Career College.
Now I have my dream job
of doing one-person reenactments
of "House Hunters" episodes.
I mean, I guess
I don't get paid for this
and I still work in retail,
but I do have
nearly 2,000 followers.
-What are you waiting for?
Speed-challenge your way through
TikTok Career College today.
Note -- by attending
TikTok Career College,
you forfeit your ownership of
your personal information,
likeness, and soul.